à 7000 km de paris les émirats arabes
unis ont fait émerger des sables un
chef-d'oeuvre la déclinaison du plus
grand musée du monde
le louvre abou dhabi imaginé il ya dix
ans par un monstre sacré de
l'architecturé contemporaine
le français jean nouvel c'est comme s'il
avait rien mais normes plage
il n'est même pas le pont encore le
grande île de sable comme ça
quand on sentait même pas l'insularité
disons d'un chantier pharaonique plus de
5000 ouvriers 600 millions d'euros de
travaux pour bâtir cette prodigieuse
coupole qui semble flotter au-dessus du
golfe persique
[Musique]
derrière le défi architectural la
bouture orientale du louvre est le fruit
d'une négociation diplomatique sans
précédent dans une des lettres envoyées
par les emiriens il y avait cette phrase
money is not problème alors à partir de
là voilà la négociation s'est engagée
sur de bonnes bases et en même temps il
y avait aussi cette espèce de fantasme
autour des émirats supposer un culte ne
comprenant rien alors juste une
pétromonarchie qui veut ajouter une
particule à sa fortune en fait
le louvre abou dhabi exporte en terre
arabe
l'ambition n'est de l'europe des
lumières d'un musée universel exposant
les trésors des civilisations
millénaires comme les grandes figures de
l'art moderne et contemporain
[Musique]
à
rien qu'à voir le concept du louvre
écrit en arabe ça permet de comprendre
la grandeur du projet comment cette
petite monarchie certes richissime s'est
elle offert la marque culturelle la plus
chic au monde
l'histoire de la première franchise du
louvre à l'étranger et celle d'un tour
de force mais sous un ciel ombrageux
ce projet fait entrer abou dhabi dans la
lumière
[Musique]
impossible de prédire au début du 20e
siècle
le destin de ce petit protectorat
britannique placée sur la route de la
soie
abu dhabi coincé entre deux puissant
voisin l'arabie saoudite et l'iran
[Musique]
c'est vraiment une culture bédouine qui
vit essentiellement de la culture et de
la pêche de la perle et avec une
dimension aussi commerciale bien
évidemment puisque ce sont des petits
miracles qui font du commerce de sète de
se perdre
[Musique]
le premier gisement de pétrole
découverts sous les sables d'abou dhabi
en 1958 sort le comptoir de sa torpeur à
lui seul l'émirat possède près de 9 %
des réserves mondiales d'or noir
[Musique]
alors que s'amorce la décolonisation
anglaise un prince bédouins prend le
contrôle de cette manne pétrolière
[Musique]
cheikh zayed qu'à ce moment-là et et
l'émir d'abou dhabi qui était l'homme
fort de ce territoire a eu l'idée de
réunir plusieurs miracles pour créer ce
qu'on a appelé la fédération des émirats
arabes unis cheikh zayed et est
considéré jusqu'à aujourd'hui comme le
père de la nation dans le sens où c'est
vraiment lui qui a commencé à utiliser
l'argent du pétrole pour développer avec
une vraie vision de ce que pouvait être
abu dhabi et de ce que pouvait être la
fédération des émirats arabes unis
[Musique]
en trente ans le fondateur des émirats
pose les bases d'un état moderne cheikh
zayed développe les infrastructures et
cultive les alliances internationales
margaret thatcher françois mitterrand
tony blair ou le président jacques
chirac courtisent ce souverain
visionnaire
en fait le projet du louvre abou dhabi
né de cette vision de cheikh zayed et de
son fils de ses fils de la volonté
d'inscrire abou dhabi dans une histoire
et que abou dhabi soit un pont entre
l'asie et l'europe
à la mort du père de la nation en 2004
ses héritiers dévoile un projet démesuré
un pôle culturel construit ex nihilo au
large de la capitale
sadia thaïlande l'île du bonheur en
arabe qui a vraiment ce qu'on appelait
le développement du soft power
abu dhabi et qui repose sur l'éducation
la culture et un peu de sport c'est la
nécessité de diversifier son économie
parce que les réserves pétrolières vont
se tarir un jour fer de lance du soft
power culturel émirien l'île du bonheur
convoque les plus grands noms de
l'architecturé mondiale frank ghery est
chargée de bâtir un nouveau guggenheim
feu l'architecte irak au britannique
zaha hadid une salle de spectacle
le musée national en l'honneur de chaque
sayyed est confiée à norman foster
tandis que le français jean nouvel et
rites
[Musique]
ce que je voulais avant tout c'est que
ce musée des racines qu'il est qu'il est
ils appartiennent et leur culture et je
voulais pas d'un musique qu'on pourrait
mettre à paris ou à londres où aux états
unis et je suis plutôt pour un musée qui
est un quartier que qu'un bâtiment qui
est un coffre fort uniquement de
protection classification donc je suis
parti dans un fragment de ville en fête
dans un quartier jean nouvel est un
bâtisseur qui ont tant marqué son époque
aucune de ses réalisations ne se
ressemble le lauréat du pritzker prize
l'équivalent du nobel d'architecturé
revendique une patte contextuel à
l'institut du monde arabe à paris
il imagine en 1987 une façade de 240
moucharabieh high tech
pour le musée du quai branly y lancastre
des cubes de couleur à une façade
végétalisée tandis qu'il recouvre la
philharmonie de paris d'oiseaux
métallique qui reflète le ciel de la
capitale
l'architecte d'être un voleur mais
c'est aussi quelqu'un qui a une mémoire
lumière qui passe à travers des planches
des sous comme ça qui font des vrais
comme ça la poussière il ya le fait de
passer sous les palmiers aussi
d'améliorations de la feuille et les
formes géométriques qui sont en dessous
tout ça oui ce sont des ce sont deux
cent des vols mais des vols d'amoureux
oh
[Musique]
on arrive en fait part ce point là on
arrive sous un auvent qui est mouvant
perforer ce qui certes pas souvent on
passe ou quelque chose qui est à moitié
ombre est perforé de lumière et en tout
de suite on se reconnaît accueillis donc
on va faire ce petit passage là comme ça
tout le long on va tourner à gauche
comme ça et puis on va voir cadrer la
mer lun premiers plans du bâtiment et le
port qui est en face
à ce moment là on est déjà dans une
ambiance un peu protégé un microclimat
perd même et 4 ou 5 degrés de différence
avec l'extérieur
c'est un peu comme à venise il ya l'eau
qui pénètre entre les différents
bâtiments et qui donc créé un phénomène
de fraîcheur son coup de maître
cette coupole de 180 mètres de diamètre
qui coiffe la ville musée
[Musique]
posé sur quatre points d'appui le dôme
pèse le poids de la tour eiffel mais
semble en lévitation au dessus des
galeries
un assemblage de huit mille étoiles
dassier qui ne laisse filtrer que
quelques rayons de l'implacable soleil
d'abou dhabi
[Musique]
cantonné dessous
on voit l'endroit où le soleil tape on
voit sur les murs et sur le sol cette
géométrie qu'on appelle nos puits de
lumière et ce phénomène change
évidemment avec les saisons avec les
verts avec des points qui apparaissent
qui disparaissent qui grandissent qui
sera petit
[Musique]
[Rires]
si on reste cinq ou six minutes devant
on voit ce mouvement là
il fallait faire quelque chose avec les
matériaux qui étaient là autrement dit
avec la mer avec le sable et avec une
amplitude du ciel qui étaient là ya pas
beaucoup de bâtiments autour il ya cette
amplitude donc ce que j'ai cherché c'est
à capter tout ça
donc à partir de là est née cette
invention ou cette lubie ou ce désir
tout d'un coup de jouer serait cinétisme
de la lumière et de coïncide avec le
souhaitant projecteurs mais qu'on doit
sentir que ce projecteur tourne autour
de la coupole
tous ces éléments là sont un peu
métaphysique quand même ils sont ils
sont là pour prouver un esprit et points
et pour créer de l'épaisseur du trait du
mystère
[Musique]
il y a dix ans l'audacieux pari émirien
d'importer le fleuron du patrimoine
hexagonal et pourtant mal engagée la
france n'a jamais exporté de biens
culturels de cette envergure
le louvre des sables devient rapidement
une affaire d'état didier seles et
l'administrateur général du louvre
lorsque les héritiers de cheikh zayed
prennent contact avec le musée français
au début de l'année 2006
[Musique]
autant on a l'habitude d'associer le
louvre au metropolitan à la national
gallery au prado autant abou dhabi on a
on avait on n'a jamais eu de relation on
ne savait même pas pour certains d'entre
nous mettra vous débit sur la carte
alors que l'elysée et matignon font
pression pour que la demande émiriennes
aboutissent les gardiens du temple s'y
opposent
[Musique]
l'idée de vendre la marque est amusé
était impensable en france
c'était même tabou c'est comme demander
de vendre son argenterie une vieille
famille ne va pas vendre son argenterie
c'est ce qu'elle garde même si elle n'a
plus rien
[Musique]
il y a eu en fait une levée de boucliers
des conservateurs français dès décembre
2006 qui avait très peur qu'on brade le
louvre qu'on prête des oeuvres qui
seraient conservés dans de mauvaises
conditions
et en fait ces conservateurs ont eu
accès à la presse il ya une tribune très
célèbre qui dénonçait une
marchandisation du louvre et des musées
français
[Musique]
il faudra toute l'habileté de didier
seles pour venir à bout des résistances
et convaincre les conservateurs que
nécessité fait loi
quand je suis arrivé au louvre en
novembre 2000 j'ai constaté avec
surprise que le nom du louvre n'étaient
pas protégés et donc j'ai déposé la
marque louvre début 2001 en me disant on
va la protéger
[Musique]
et quand il ya eu ensuite la demande des
émirs hien leurs projets à ce moment là
donc j'ai dit mais on ne peut pas ne pas
valoriser le nom du louvre le nom du
louvre c'est exceptionnel il n'a jamais
été prêté et ça vaut de l'or
en échange de son nom du prêt de ses
oeuvres et de son expertise
le louvre négocié un contrat de prêt
d'un milliard d'euros une manne
providentielle pour ce musée au
fonctionnement coûteux une victoire
politique pour renaud donnedieu de
vabres qui signait un accord
intergouvernemental historique le 6 mai
2007 à abou dhabi
à son retour à paris le ministre de la
culture de dominique de villepin jubile
en conseil des ministres j'ai dis donc
avec un peu d'humour
le ministre des vieilles pierres et des
troubadours vient de rapporter à son
pays
sur la longue période plus d'un milliard
d'euros avant que l'un d'entre vous en
fasse autant pour notre pays
beaucoup d'eau a coulé sous la scène
sous les ponts de la seine et donc je
vais avoir longtemps la parole la chirac
m'a interrompu les eaux
c'est moi qui donne la parole autour de
la table du conseil des ministres donc
voilà on accomplit que tu es content je
le suis aussi
et nous allons passer aux dossiers
suivants loin des intrigues parisienne
les vrais gagnants de l'accord sont
émirati le pays s'offrent davantage car
label prestigieux
[Musique]
rita hoon fut l'émissaire des chèques au
prix du louvre pendant les négociations
ce n'est pas juste un projet qui est
sorti de nulle part et qui est juste
pour attirer les touristes
ce n'est pas un projet de luxe ce n'est
pas un projet pour dire voilà on a une
collection on amuse et c'est un besoin
c'est d'abord pourrait essayer vraiment
de pouvoir exister de manière très forte
dans une région qui est quand même
sujette à des replis identitaires à des
conflits
[Musique]
abu dhabi frappe fort dans la guerre d'
influence qu'il livre à ses voisins le
qatar et dubaï
dubaï a choisi d'être la vitrine
mondiale du tourisme de luxe royaume du
clinquant et des centres commerciaux des
mesures et quant au qatar il assure son
rayonnement par des investissements
massifs dans le sport
achat du paris saint-germain de neymar
le joueur le plus cher du monde
et organisation de la coupe du monde de
football en 2022
[Musique]
ces pays du golfe n'ont de cesse que
d'acheter des sécurités d'acheter les
assurances vie parce que ce sont deux
pays qui sont en dépit de leur richesse
foncièrement fragile je crois que le
louvre abou dhabi est extrêmement
important parce que c'est une marque qui
était qu'à une marque et une résonance
sur la scène internationale pas que vous
avez de la france et que le qatar ça ne
l'a pas le qatar a des beaux musées mais
le qatar n'a pas le louvre
[Musique]
pour être à la hauteur de l'ambition
universel du louvre les emiriens ont
investi 40 millions d'euros par an
constituant en pièce après pièce une
collection permanente de la préhistoire
à nos jours
bon
un peu
cet élégant bodhisattva du 3ème siècle
après jésus-christ provenant du pakistan
le chef-d'oeuvre d'edouard manet père de
l'impressionnisme le bohémien
ou encore cette belle anthropométrie
d'yves klein ou l'artiste et sa femme
ont laissé l'empreinte de leurs corps
font partie des plus belles acquisitions
un fonds de 600 chef-d'oeuvre gauguin
mondrian magritte dont seule la moitié
est exposé les prémices d'une collection
ambitieuse mise en scène par son
directeur scientifique
jean-françois charniers on a souhaité
que le visiteur arrivants se retrouve
comme en fait un voyageurs débarquant
sur l'île de saadiyat découvrant en fait
le musée au sol on voit des lignes
géométriques qui part de cette rose des
vents ces lignes géométriques se
croisent ce sont celles en fait d'un
portulans une carte marie du 13ème 14ème
siècle qui croise la ligne de littoral
ici que ce qui est le littoral des
émirats arabes unis avec des noms qui
sont indiqués qu'ils soient en fait les
noms des lieux de la création de ces
oeuvres
ça donne le sentiment que toutes ces
oeuvres se sont rencontrés à abu dhabi
et que abou dhabi se trouve ici dans
cette réflexion ou un peu au centre du
monde
un carrefour de civilisations qui
inspire et aux jeunes conservateurs
cette muséographie unique au monde
là on a trois masque en or qui viennent
de monde différentes civilisations
différentes vous avez le proche orient
ici avec un très beau masque funéraire
vous avez la chine avec ce masque liao
et vous avez l'amérique précolombienne
avec ce masque vient du mexique qui sont
en fait trois rapports similaires à la
matière lors matière-lumière matière
éternel matière incorruptibles on les
met ensemble parce que on souhaite
montrer qu' il ya une convergence de ce
rapport à ses valeurs fondamentales
cette relation à la mort et à l'éternité
ça montre qu'on partage des valeurs
communes
dans l'humanité et pas simplement des
différences si le louvre abou dhabi a pu
lancer ses ponts entre les mondes
c'est grâce à un accès inédit au
patrimoine culturel français
aux côtés du louvre de la bibliothèque
nationale au château de versailles
douze des plus grands musées de france
se sont engagées à prêter leurs oeuvres
iconique
le musée d'orsay s'est ainsi séparé
temporairement de cet autoportrait de
vincent van gogh ou de la gare
saint-lazare de claude monet
la belle ferronnière de léonard de vinci
a quitté le louvre le rocher rouge de
paul cézanne a été décrochés des murs du
musée de l'orangerie tandis que le
centre pompidou prête ce sublime
giacometti
au fil des salles un dialogue entre les
oeuvres apparaît
[Musique]
des influences des métissages qui
permettent à jean-françois charniers
l'anthropologue de questionner notre
identité autour du 500 avant notre ère
vous avez à la fois
bhutta en inde confucius en chine et
socrate en europe qui pense l'homme dans
sa cité son destin individuel son destin
collectif et qui va marquer profondément
l'histoire de la pensée et l'histoire
continental donc il est intéressant de
les mettre ensemble au louvre abou dhabi
on l'aimé l'ensemble je crois que j'ai
jamais vu notre exemple dans aucun autre
musée qui les mettent ensemble
je souhaiterais que le visiteur
sentiment que sa propre identité à lui
se construit dans la relation aux autres
que lui-même comprennent que l'ouverture
aux autres et la rencontre à l'autre est
un moment clé de son épanouissement de
son devenir de son développement c'est
une part d'humanisme en fait il un
message humaniste au louvre abou dhabi
le l'importance de l'autre de l'altérité
dans la construction de sa propre
identité
[Musique]
les artisans de ce musée propose une
oasis d'universalisme dans un monde
fragmenté
une utopie humaniste qui se joue des
frontières dans une région sous haute
tension
la proposition du conservateur fait écho
aux voyages métaphysique auquel
l'architecte du louvre des sables invite
les visiteurs
[Musique]
tous ces éléments ensemble créé je crois
une sérénité
un calme et ouvre je dirais l'esprit
vers une méditation propice à regarder
des comparaisons entre ces objets
souvent millénaire et quelquefois
actuelle
on est dans cette lecture du temps et
dans cette lecture d'objets qui viennent
d'ailleurs et qui se rencontrent là
c'est un lieu de rencontres spirituelles
[Musique]